hey youtubers next Startalk cosmic
queries space week this is Startalk your
host Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and this is a cosmic
queries edition where we are celebrating
space week that would be the first week
of October that happens to contain my
birthday
I'm just saying whoo oh yeah I've got my
co-host for this Matt kirshen Matt
welcome back
Thank You Neil excellent what came first
by the way a space week or your birthday
did it become space week because it was
the Neil deGrasse Tyson birthday my
birthday precedes the official
celebration of space week yeah so maybe
maybe that was the designation maybe I
got a lot of fun questions coming up we
show then I got back up here I'm his
backup if he's on a show with me I'm his
backup the one the only the geek in
chief Charles Liu I am so happy to be
here thank you friend and colleague
you're a professor that City University
of New York in Staten Island correct and
so you just had a book come out yes
thank you
yeah it's called 32nd universe published
by ivy Press in the u k-- is occurs
there 31 are the universe the third a
second one I asked the very same
question the parsing is 30 - second
every every decision that's made the
universe splits into 31 decisions that
nobody wanted well it's only to make 32
decisions that's only what is it it's
like five right no yes it is about
cosmology and I have two terrific
co-authors who are also astronomy and
physics professors and we talk that
mothers are Karen masters
Matan Haverford University in Haverford
College and Seville saloon at Rutgers
University okay cool and we talk about
cosmology including the idea in quantum
mechanics that you create many worlds
with a hypothesis every split with every
decision you make and create a new
timeline which I believe was originally
formulated by the father of the lead
singer of one of my favorite bands
oh uh I but I believe it was Hugh
Everett the physicist who came up with
that shoe does get credit for okay whose
son created the band eels no kidding and
another connection between science and
music you got that you got it and
Mathieu of course the host of probably
science that's it and I said it would
never invite you back until it became
definitely the one episode that you were
kind enough to come on that was the
definite episode you hosted me on your
shows very you're very kind to come by
that yeah so we've got questions from
our fan base as we usually solicit
cosmic queries and this is just I guess
general I haven't seen them general
questions about space you're gonna
handpick them I am you're gonna throat
throw down the gauntlet
ooh and Charles I'll sit here and eat my
lunch that's why I bring him on okay
just have very strongly overlapping Venn
diagrams in our expertise but he takes
it he takes it another dimension beyond
that I'm sweating now so we're good I
don't know we can see how good you know
I'm gonna start off with this one
because this this ties in to what we
were just talking about this is from DQ
fam who says what platform on twitter is
DQ at flat not on Twitter I think that's
actually relevant to this question
because DQ fam aka flat North says is
there a parallel universe where I as an
astrophysicist on the Flat Earth combat
the disinformation agenda of the round
earth society way to start us off with
an easy well the short answer is no
because next question but I think we can
take this in a direction where we
imagine that he actually is in a flat
universe a two-dimensional universe
where somebody says no actually the
universe is three dimensional right now
remember the beautiful book flatland for
inhabit yeah yeah some decades ago where
you go yeah it's been essentially yeah
there's turn-of-the-century books yeah
yeah but the end of the previous century
right fair enough how can we prove
that the universe is two-dimensional if
indeed it is two-dimensional where
someone is claiming that there's a third
dimension right mmm
I I would approach it this way well
you're talking about the whole universe
you just talk about Earth's right so I
guess to the universe is two dimensions
Earth has to be a flat disk correct Oh
got you right for us so in that sense
right then some some non-scientific
individual comes along and says the
universe is a three-dimensional
structure and the earth is actually a
three-dimensional structure how would
you counter that right and so that makes
it a more interesting question and I
would say one of the first things you
would try to do is to see if you can
prove that the two-dimensional universe
cannot project into the third in other
words you cannot find a way to extend
the universe in an orthogonal direction
to promote yeah perpend excuse me yes
you can't extend something perpendicular
to both length and width now can you do
that in any but what you're saying is in
our current universe yeah we have a
height width depth yes and you're saying
that the version of that question to us
would be fine another place to stick out
a line that's at right angles to those
three other right angles yeah we don't
know how to do that right and so that
would be that way that someone in a true
two-dimensional universe just trying to
say that there is no third dimension oh
that I'm marryin thinking there there
are some theories of physics that
involve higher spatial dimensions in our
universe Oh completely
but those conventions are not visible to
us okay and one of the well-known
formulations of this is something called
a compactive by Charles you're ok with
this do these actual dimensions we just
can't see them you're okay with that I'm
not okay with it yet okay but they
haven't been disproven okay here's the
idea that the compactified dimension if
our length was actually you zoom in
further and further and further and you
find out that our length is actually has
length width and height but it's so
small compared to even atoms or
subatomic particles that that width and
height is not detectable in our universe
it's tantamount to just being a one as
you're
were one-dimensional order all intents
and purposes is that where they use the
word compactified is yes it's contained
tightly within right you can imagine for
example looking at the alaska pipeline
if you're standing right next to the
Alaska Pipeline
it is obviously both with length and
width additionally it has height so it's
a three dimensional object you step a
little further away it just becomes like
a long strip so you think it has height
and length but you can't see the depth
anymore
and then if you fly away say to Canada
and you're looking at the Alaska
Pipeline from a distance it only looks
like a line by that same token we could
compactify dimensions into our linear
dimensions that's how you get the harder
dimension yeah even though you can't
experience them right and somehow if you
think that those compactified dimensions
can affect our universe in ways we can't
measure then you can say set up a
universe with multiple dimensions and
what you're saying is we're too big
we are not cool verse for which we are
very very tiny we are still way too big
to see hypothesize compactify dimension
and we're too small to see that earth is
a sphere yes we just we just walk in a
straight line
uh-huh and it's a straight line to you
yeah but if you back out there's you're
walking on a surface of a sphere and
even know it okay and so that's how you
would try to address two dimension three
dimension more dimension type but I love
the questions yeah you're very clever I
love the question and I love that answer
okay this is more of a that's why we
have them on the show that's accident
drop off the car vegetable cart I
thought is for the snacks that I they
were great snacks thank you so this is
more of a practical question from CMOS
star on Instagram will we focus more on
habitable planets or all rich planets in
the future that's or Ori okay or rich
because I would focus on rich planets if
it's just orbited like you know do
business with them but or rich planets I
think are not as interesting as
habitable planets and the reason is to
go to another planet
that is trillions of miles away to get a
little bit of ore and then bring it back
to earth is really impractical you can't
hardly imagine a substance currently
known to science for which that would be
profitable or economically feasible
right you have of course the science
fiction world where you imagine
something called oh I don't know
unobtainium sure yeah which could not be
obtained here on earth and therefore you
must go far away to get it but that
seems extremely unlikely to me so I
would much rather find the blue-skinned
creatures than the unobtanium I agree
with you scientifically ok but as like a
practical guy as a realist okay
I think the drive to obtain resources
and possibly unobtainium will be greater
than the drive to find other life oh and
the more busy we are in space the less
will be the need to bring the resources
back to earth compared with bringing the
resources to other on-site location oh
that has value you're thinking much
further in the future than yeah yeah
that makes a lot of sense because I can
certainly see and then you don't give
any plant asteroids might have this now
that's that's the thing that I wanted to
point out I'd still claim the first
trillionaire the first trillionaire will
be the person who exploits and hassled
resources of asteroids well there is
there is a connected question here from
SCI Gaikai on Twitter okay what are the
most what are the most common precious
metals and useful elements found in
asteroids could we mine asteroids to
build components for starships in space
shipyards um I would say the rare earths
are more important or asteroid - yeah
well I think Oliver I mean you know
microchips yeah yeah the rare earths by
the way the rare earths are not
particularly rare they're just mostly in
China so access to them is not as free
and and smooth as we might want right
the future of our technology and as
Charles noted the rare earth elements
are fundamental to what is our
electronic components to making them
work and do their thing so
so yeah i i i think it's the first
trillionaire and do all their on the
asteroids right yard Adam yeah the
challenge is to get them back to earth
you got to get their fine but then you
have to mine them and you got to bring
him back and mining is actually pretty
complicated there's a lot of this ship
in space do don't bring it back to earth
it's a waste of a whole journey bill
just that's what the question is right
then how do you get the people from
earth to the spaceship you still need
another space robot to do it no robots
build that spaceship and then you go up
when it's time again there's an app for
that
yeah your spaceship is ready sir you you
are definitely looking much further
along the time horizon than I am okay
and I think that's a fair statement I I
will agree with you if we're talking
centuries not decade money drives things
more than curiosity unfortunately the
ideal part is to combine the curiosity
with the money yeah then then it happens
like that yeah
here is a Twitter question from George
Xenophon toss this is more of an
earth-based question why haven't there
been a greater number of advancements on
solar energy given that it's literally a
constant free source of energy okay
Charles I I have been on my soapbox on
this with my astronomy students ever
since I started teaching okay solar
energy is so plentiful it's so free you
make the calculation in fact we're not
so free mean okay that's my point free
is Right free that's it means that I
don't need to pay for the energy to
arrive to my house free okay that's the
free the rest of it is the thing that
costs money right think about this the
amount of energy that the Sun sends onto
the surface of the earth is what we call
it a unit of insulation right in so
Latian with an O as supposed to
insulation that's a real word yeah in a
solution there scientists use it do you
think that's great we don't know it
really all right any soul isolation yes
is just amount of sunlight yeah the soul
is Latin for Sun right yeah it's the
amount of sunlight that hits the earth
well any planet but in this case the
insulation on
earth is at a rate of 1400 watts per
square meter mm-hmm okay what does that
mean our typical LED light bulb is now
14 watts as most yeah right
so on every but just on the table in
front of us just on any street table
yeah coffee table on any surface you are
getting enough light energy if it were
properly converted to be able to
illuminate a hundred lightbulbs worth of
light alan johnson you ously
continuously forever 100 light 400 most
houses don't have a hundred right so you
can literally light every house in the
world on this free energy if we just
figured out a way to exploit it and I
believe sadly that the main reason we
have not done so is because people find
it more profitable to exploit energy
sources that are much older in their
origins our ability to say it oil to sit
just say it they say I don't want to I
don't want to diss older sources of
energy because as much trouble as they
have caused us in an environmental
levels they have also advanced
civilization yeah they've advanced us so
much in so many ways in the past couple
of centuries old coil not to go oil yeah
oil coal natural gas these fossil fuels
have really spurred our human ability to
be where we are today but it is time to
switch over and as with anything in
society switching over from something
old to something new takes time there's
resistance the resistance should move
away at this point there is no more
reason for us not to switch except for
trying to preserve the prosperity and
the interests of those who have become
wealthy right the old side I've seen
technologies like I I don't know how far
along it is but I know they've trialed
things like road surfaces that have
solar cells built into them that's right
and you could put solar cells on
buildings you like not just on the roofs
but there are windows now where people
can put a film on them and if you want
shade in your room you just turn the
film over and then all that sunlight
instead of going into your room gets
absorbed by this film which can then be
converted into electricity as long as we
are willing to take a short-term hit on
profits we will have a long-term benefit
by using more solar well maybe it won't
happen until we figure out how to make
it instantly profitable who would have
thought that after millennia of riding
horses within a dozen 15 years we
switched over to cars ISM at some point
somebody said this car is more
economical than my horse right then
feeding my horse and the care and
feeding of a huge animal and so at some
point that happened because nobody had
to have special programs to get you to
buy a car all right everybody bought
cars
is there a tipping point yes there you
go I don't tipping I don't see an
obvious one either unfortunate how does
it work also the resources well we just
talking about mining for rare metals and
elements in the universe the resources
needed currently to make solar cells do
we have enough of those yes we do the
vast majority of what we need is just a
really good silicon
oh so that's sand mm-hmm we can
basically take sand from pretty much
anywhere and turn them into solar
silicon dioxide yes yes it is not hard
okay it's just at the moment it costs
money and people would rather not spend
that money I
I myself you know am guilty of saying
gee I should really put solar panels on
my roof and then just go home and watch
TV yes because it is much less expensive
for me as a consumer yeah to heat my
home with natural gas right now or to
light my home with the world with cold
first adopters tend to be rich yeah and
they'll do it so they have bragging
rights that they're they're more doing
right and you are right but that helps
to change the infrastructure that when
they have it the good news is that
prices for solar electricity generating
things are going down rapidly I will add
before we take a quick break that solar
power is also hydroelectric because how
do you think the water gets up to the
lake before it comes to her life even
Sarmatian off the ocean was a cloud the
cloud moves over land it rains so let's
take technically solar power and so is
wind energy it's all from the Sun yeah
the unequal heating of the Earth's
surface creates air currents that drive
so the Sun manifests in more than just
whether you need a solar we got to take
a quick break and when we come back more
of our cosmic queries space we condition
back on Startalk cosmic queries space we
condition
Charles Luke friend and colleague thank
you he's my expertise here and I'm just
gonna tell her comment and I think he
misses something which he hardly ever
does oh I'm in there but generally I'm
not saying a thing Matt gherkin welcome
back thank you so right take us take us
there you got questions all right I did
hold from our fan base I love this fan
base this one is from snarky and they're
funny and they're smart yeah and smartly
they're really good questions this one's
from Kyle Yocum who has helpfully given
a pronunciation guide in case we have
Chuck nice because Chuck pronounced Kyle
is from Tennessee and asks how would we
identify something as truly being of
another universe rather than just a
newly discovered part of our own oh wow
and I think I know the answer to that
and it's antennae be very irritated no
they're from our universe to but this
one I would have to think to chemistry
if an object is made of something that
is an element of something we have never
seen before something that wouldn't fit
on our periodic table for any reason hmm
that one would have to come from a place
where the laws of physics are different
and thus a different universe I agree
entirely our periodic table of elements
is full yeah we're incrementing at the
top end in our in our labs but there are
no no more slots rattle okay
and if they come up with something that
is a base element yeah then it's going
to be an element configured in some way
that our elements are not configured
right and we say yeah this is a this is
a weird bird right it's similar in a
sense that an expanded version of how we
know that there is material in our solar
system that came from outside our solar
system before the Sun was born there are
grains that contain carbon nano diamonds
basically I just have to be before our
son was born doesn't have to be it just
be visiting yeah it could just be visit
like floating into our solar system from
there but we know if it's from outside
our solar system if we compare their
isotopic ratios
or their structures and we see that
there's nothing that matches that age or
that mixed position that is actually of
our solar system so we have ways to do
this so but that's what fine but then
you say how did it get what portal
through the space-time continuum
connected to different universes with
two different laws of physics and that's
what that's what the real issue will be
yeah well I was gonna do a different
question but since you talked about
portals through the space-time continuum
I'm going you went there no I went there
first yeah I'm gonna go with a Tony in
the 8:45 on Twitter who asked even if we
somehow discovered the tech to travel at
or faster-than-light with the passengers
of the vehicles survived oh well you
know how the flash does it right we have
atmospheric separators in front of him
that the flash can go up to the speed of
light super hero fake science all that
right but if he's giving someone a
piggyback yeah
that person is toast really what's note
to self went offered a piggyback ride by
just doing like a donkey ride around the
living room
well yeah so the the issue here is that
if we take something up to the speed of
light and it can survive going the speed
of light then it has to be able to
protect whatever's inside it to be able
also to match the speed of light so
remember that as you get closer and
closer to the speed of light and once
you reach the speed of light you cannot
have mass anymore you are energy by
definition so the way to get up to the
limit is to have a really good strong
shielding of whatever's there but then
getting past it well I work on
interstellar particle Springs okay
stuff that could slam into yes that's it
hits only hit you at the speed of light
that would hurt yeah a lot and that's
its light funny yeah that's what the
sunscreen is for yeah yes
so force field yeah yes you would have
to find a way for this vehicle itself to
survive and by extension whatever's
inside the vehicle would survive as well
anything piggyback though probably would
be burn to it but I want to make
something clear that speed does not kill
its acceleration that kills mmm right
okay so you can be cruising at 99.99%
the speed of light no one will know and
no one will care but if you abruptly
come to zero or if you abruptly speed up
to that then you're a pile of goo at the
back of this base so if you could be
MAGIX into the middle of something that
was already moving at the speed of light
or at 99% of the speed of light things
accelerate their slowly right you can do
that in fact they have spaceships we can
see tweet I mean people engineers yeah
we can see the spaceships that
accelerate at 1 G 1 earth gravity then
it just feels like you're just sitting
here like we're having this conversation
but we're going faster and faster and
faster and how do you remember how
quickly you get to the speed of light
near the speed like six months it's not
that bad it's not even a year within a
year but then doesn't then you have to
slow down it also takes but you just
turn the ship around and slow down in
that direction so you still right but it
doesn't your mast then increase as your
mass increases relative to other things
around you okay so we didn't the
spaceship this was some moving at that
speed right right so you and I would
maintain our relative masses but you and
I would not retain our relative masses
compared to you know zorkin who's out
you know try to gain some masks
yeah how much faster do I have to run in
silicon look beach ready yes there you
go summers coming up while we're talking
about a summer and atmosphere and uh
such Lake times natural on Instagram
asked if Mars would be terraformed thus
given an earthlike atmosphere how would
it be possible to keep the atmosphere
from being blown away by solar winds
considering Mars does not have the
magnetic protection that's right it's a
good question I think the first question
which is even more important
is Mars doesn't have the gravity to hold
on to our atmosphere we if we tried to
put as much atmosphere on earth it would
the tops of it would continuously be
going away before we could develop
enough pressure on the surface to get to
say Earth atmospheric pressure so the
answer is it just has to be constantly
being generated okay Charles there's
clearly evidence of it once having had
running water on its surface
yes so they had to be enough air
pressure to prevent the water from just
evaporating and that had to have been
sustained for some fair amount of time
because some of the rivers are
meandering yes and that's a slow yes you
don't just get that for free we're
talking about millions of years right
the the maybe even up to a billion years
okay when Mars like any other planet in
our solar system was forming the core
was slowly aggregating its metals from
the surface right it's a differentiation
process where just the same way that
pulp in orange juice sinks to the bottom
so too is the metals like there's coal
back to the bottom eventually my poop
float oh oh so if you were given time
yeah okay give it there I got floaty
pulp I want to drink your orange but no
I will actually separate that's right
your separation of the orange juice is
an analogy to the separation of like a
metal core and a rocky mantle and then a
rocky crust on the outside right we
think of rocks as heavy but they're
light compared to metal yeah so they
explode right okay but when the matter
sinks heat is dissipated outward gently
but with vigor into the surroundings the
crust and eventually the atmosphere in
that process you can get a lot of
outgassing from underneath the surface
out onto the surface which means that
you can for many millions of years while
that's happened while it's happening
sustain the atmosphere and that will
create meandering rivers that you do
right so I believe that does it doesn't
take a million years to me under a river
right but it may take that much time to
say evolve a proto virus yes you're
right so the answer is the same answer
that no we cannot prevent it from going
away either because of magnetic fields
not being there nor by not enough
gravity instead we just have to keep
generating more and more atmosphere at
the surface so that we can maintain
equilibrium even as the outer layers are
going just to be clear that made any
field shields us from particles from the
Sun that would otherwise basically pick
off the fashion right atoms would they
be other problems as well being on Mars
then without that she'll dance so wins
his right when you have it's not just
magnetic field it's also isn't also the
ozone because that UV from the Sun
ultraviolet break apart the water
molecule and make it h2o and the H is
hydrogen the lightest element and it
moves very fast in any thermal
environment you lose that and so leave
stranding the oxygen behind so you
systematically molecule by molecule take
out your water that's right and that's
not add nothing to do with the magnetic
field yeah there's all kinds of problems
even uh when you don't have a protection
against ionizing radiation of any kind
whether they be light like gamma rays
and x-rays or whether they be charged
particles well just good let's just go
out and say if you can terraform Mars
you can put a big magnet magnet they
will walk around with like an umbrella
yeah the engineers will find a stanchion
- no one can stand to post a fridge I
think yeah I think the the terraforming
reality is that you are gonna have to
live in domes in a place like Mars you
can't just leave it open that would be
funny if they had magnet on the helmet
to close your refrigerator it's like the
moderates are getting your tongue stuck
yeah that would be funny uh which I
think as a scientist you know if that
happens the best thing to do is just
keep pulling just keep oh yeah it'll
snap in and roll up and roll
little roll-up yes that's how it works
we heard it here from two scientists
well we've got scientists here as well
one hive Gazette on patreon who asks
I've heard there are benefits to putting
a space telescope on the far side of the
Moon I think because Earth's radio
emissions won't cause interference there
do you think there will eventually be a
telescope stationed there what exactly
would be the benefits on that's also
there's a name at the end of that as
well that's Patrick Follis from Mill
Creek
well Patrick yes there should be a
telescope there and there are many
benefits I attended an entire conference
on this only a few astronomy from the
far side of the Moon and it was it was a
delight just to see because we're
nowhere near getting there yeah
but to see these early ideas why it's
useful yeah we are a radio noisy place
and radio telescopes need this this
radio silence it's it's basically well
it's noise in the traditional sense it's
it's electromagnetic noise noise signals
that you don't want to be there because
you're trying to detect something that's
dimmer than and all them and and would
it all be blocked out by being on the
other side of the family yeah it doesn't
have to penetrate through the moon right
so there aren't like we can go round off
there is some diffraction a little bit
but if you're a smack dab on the other
side of the moon earth is dead to you
you should be able to avoid it so for
example spacecraft now which have landed
on the far side of the moon can
communicate with earth because there is
a satellite in orbit around the moon
bounces it right exactly so any
civilization back any any colony would
have to have some kind of way to bounce
off of the side of the moon to come
straight back to us either by permanent
stations like like towers they can talk
to each other by the way it's like those
sort of look behind glosses that spies
have yes I get from the back of magazine
happen to those spider-man still uses
really
according to doesn't you spidey sense
glory use a google glasses to see behind
according to information from decades
ago which may have been you know
outpaced by 21st century technology
spider-man's
Mask doesn't actually have eye holes and
he actually sees through mirrors that's
off to the side really I didn't know
that yeah I do also like to think that
all spies still buy their stuff from the
back of Joe magazines visibly that's how
I got my Charles Atlas you know a body
in a 7 day and it is a remarkable and
x-ray specs you want to see the bones
right people's bones yeah which would
also enable you to see through the moon
to earth so you wouldn't have any of
that problem yeah yeah so it's a great
idea especially for radio telescopes but
it isn't yet and and radio telescopes
especially are big and that's one of the
reasons why you can't just send them out
into space far enough away from Earth to
not be affected by the radio oh is that
was gonna be my next question is why you
can't just sort of put it on a moon
lander and then drive it across to the
far side
I mean radio telescopes are big right if
you remember the movie contact Jodie
Foster right is sitting in just one
antenna of the Very Large Array in New
Mexico okay so that single antennas much
much larger than she wasn't in the
antenna she was like at the base of it
oh why don't you well she was at Arecibo
telescope that's right and she was even
at close to the edge yet close yeah yeah
Britta talks are big the because radio
waves are big and to get a lot of radio
waves to focus them you need a bigger
dish and then you'd otherwise think you
need so yeah and since the far side also
gets sunlight it's not the Dark Side of
the Moon so it's not like you're in
eternal darkness which might be an
astronomers dream state but a day on the
moon last a moons all sides get sunlight
and radio 15 days of darkness 15 days of
radio astronomers can actually work in
the daytime
although which is one of the coolest
things ever which is really really cool
although the Sun is a big source of
radio noise so there are a lot of
trade-offs back and forth but it's
really cool there's a zone around the
Sun you want to keep clear of it because
it'll be too noisy so worse than Earth
yeah where would the best place to be a
telescope on the moon
yeah or anywhere if you could put a
telescope anywhere in the universe why
would you put it over the place you're
looking at with the telescope yeah all
right well that's a fair point
between galaxies
yeah we're it's dark and there's no
thing then just go to where you're
looking right I think you sometimes want
the sort of the white of you the comfort
of just sitting back and taking all the
repoint right no I would be I would be
more excited about getting a big
telescope then putting the telescope in
any given location if we can get a
telescope that's the size of the solar
system or the size of the Milky Way
galaxy now we can put that anywhere that
it doesn't get broken and I'm totally
cool yeah yeah that's a good point you
can make much bigger structures in space
bigger than Earth itself yeah and then
you got the baddest-ass telescope so
that would be another useful once you
get the technology to stop building
stuff with robots yes yeah well it's the
first thing we build with a robot in
space using asteroids a telescope I
would yeah but this probably not there's
probably not any economic driver for
that probably this uh this question
comes from Maz amou on instagram who
says how would you mark it as in quotes
space exploration to someone with an
extremely utilitarian view I'm
definitely not the one who needs
convincing but that type of criticism is
abundant nowadays and then also lots of
love from your fans in Dubai Dubai very
interesting cool well the answer to that
is we don't have time we're gonna take a
break and when we come back we're gonna
find out how to how to convert the
non-believers in space exploration when
Startalk returns
back on Startalk Tyson here draw glue
there Matt kirshen there and we are
commemorating space week and just to
remind people in case you didn't know
the first week of October happened to
have been the week that Sputnik was
launched October 4th 1957 by the
Russians Soviet Union our sworn enemy
the godless communists and we lost our
it would take us a year but a year
later in the first week of October we
would found NASA NASA would be become an
agency but later so those two events
both happening October as well as many
other space missions that have occurred
in October have made a perfectly good
argument to call this space week yeah I
think it's great so we are cosmic
queries so keep going Matt so this is
the question from just before the break
is how would you mock its space
exploration to non-believers so someone
would be an extremely utilitarian view
yeah Charlie what would you do well your
educator United States space enthusiasts
what would you write well I have to use
many different strategies with my
students I often teach introductory
astronomy classes where most of the
students are not going to become
scientists okay right so how do you
convince them that it's a good idea to
go out into space I think there's a very
good and you have to use many different
strategies one strategy being in the
utilitarian side is to convince people
that profit can be made right the same
way that people came to North America
from Europe a new world yeah back in the
1600s was precisely people convincing
others that if you send me to America
I can make money for you and send back
stuff for you whether it's gold
whether it's beaver pelts whether it's
agricultural goods things like that name
places off to you for example yes so
they weren't very creative they all
begin with the word new a New Haven New
York yeah new you know everything is New
England no is the whole place so that
profit is a utilitarian thing you can do
right another thing is
you appeal to their sense of grandeur
grandiosity vanity of Eagle depending I
go yeah and say if you go out there you
could be the person that everyone will
remember for all of human history right
a lot of times people will ask me that
and and younger kids for example ask me
some scientific question which we don't
know the answer to and there are many of
those right I will say something along
the lines of you know what nobody knows
yet maybe someday you will be the person
that discovers that and then we will all
remember you and your scientific
discovery I have a better answer
ooh here's what you do you go to that
person who's the nan note okay go to
that person and in the dark of night
sneak into their place oh yeah that's an
eel so he goes away you do this with a
search warrant okay okay then you remove
everything in their home that was
inspired to develop because of space
technology oh so first you take away the
smartphone then you take away all
integrated circuits and all of this take
away their uber account take away their
health their LASIK surgery their steak
and all of this right
they do it and then they wake up and
they take what and they take take away
weather
what's the weather channel they look for
to take away what all the weather
forecasting
take it away at all and then just leave
them there bare assed so then they learn
quickly what role space is played in
yeah you really can say that space
technology basic science those kinds of
things that do not change the price of
bread today can and have change the
course of civilization tomorrow and we
want to be martyrs out there don't add
words to that okay
just the way came out of your mouth all
right yeah printed on the t-shirt you
gotta know when to stop the beautiful
quote it won't change the price of bread
today but it could change the course of
civilization tomorrow all right next
question
well I'm gonna combine these two
questions because they are
it allowed little out judges absolutely
well I credit both these people that
it's a continuation what we were talking
about
but Jared Decker asks in the future will
it be government the private sector or a
combination of the both that will
continue humanity's journey through
space okay and then Paul ponder on
Twitter asks as Neil Tyson at Neil Tyson
stated in his book military and science
flourished together there are chances
that the next scientific breakthrough
happened but is classified by the
government thoughts Oh
mm-hmm well that's already happened it's
very true that's wrong you're not
authorized to go there oh I'm sorry
you're right you're right sorry okay no
it could never happen
no Neil did Neil has written very
eloquently about this particular topic
and so I'm gonna defer to you in your
conversation about the military aspect
of things but but I will say from my
purely civilian point of view to me the
reason the military and the government
and industry all work together to move
us forward in technology development and
innovation is simply because you need a
lot of resources in any society to do
those kinds of things
innovation is almost never just one guy
in his basement
right that's just not how we're gonna
move so I get a movie made after you
yeah the one person burning that's not
oil that's right he's if it's it if it's
ten people taking five years in a lab
funded by five different sources nobody
makes a movement I think that's right
and and our reality is as again as Neil
has written is that many many many hands
are necessary and much much much money
is needed to make those really
fundamental explorations what do you
think you know I do you know
christiaan huygens yes he's a Dutch a
polymath yeah he's credited with the
rings of Saturn identifying understand
understanding that they are rings yeah
he did a wave theory of light yes and he
actually has a spacecraft the Huygens
probe named after him the one that
landed on Saturn's moon Titan detached
from yeah from utiful from and show me
show those amazing pictures that showed
that on Titan there are mountains and
rivers and lakes just like we see on
earth but they're made of very different
substances
they're made of methane so Huygens and
one of his books hypothesizes that God
put evil people on earth so that good
people would have to innovate on a war
against them by inventing new tools and
technology Wow and this is the source of
civilization because we have bad people
on earth and this was part of God's plan
you've rights this Wow almost like this
is how this is how connected and
convinced he is with innovation in war
go hand in hand amazing yeah
if you are if you're just using military
resources and then turning them to
purely discovery purposes yeah and then
that that's a different dynamic than
what you're describing in terms of like
the actual desire to wage war that's an
excellent point
oh so and to the answer I think like
Charles it will be a combination
government will do some things first
because there's not a profit motive yet
until the the trade winds are mapped and
the hospitals and the friendlies are
established then private enterprise can
come in I say this often that the first
Europeans to the new world were not the
Dutch East India Trading Company
there was governments who took that
first investment for hegemonist ik
regions and economic reasons and then I
mean well long-term economic reasons
they then then once you know and it's
mapped this how much it cost this is how
long it took this is what you can bring
back now I can make a business model I
can sell tickets and now we can we have
the Dutch East India Trading Company
right yeah right that's a good point we
gotta go into lightning round
oh all right around reminder lightning
round is sambar dancers okay all right
you see how good you've come you
waiter I don't know I don't know Matt go
all right Cory moon on Twitter no
relation to AL moon says has a nuclear
bomb ever been tested in space if so
what happens not to my knowledge
but if it does happen then the radiation
just goes a long long way
half of why one would use a nuclear
weapon is for the blast wave that does
most of the immediate damage well it's
the three ways atomic weapons work one
is the the blast of light energy that
will vaporize things on the spot the
next is the blast wave that any typical
bomb would have the third is the
radiation sickness that would then kill
living things in space if there is no
air then the blast wave does not exist
and half of why you would ever use the
bomb is nullified so but you do get the
radio if you do get the radiation and
you get the light energy right on top
which is also electromagnetic oh yeah I
don't know if we've ever exploded a bomb
in space all right Thomas
Kastner on Twitter says Star Trek
included many aliens and creatures that
naturally existed in space outside of
planetary atmospheres is that possible
anything is possible can it be done with
the DNA structure that we're used to
probably not I agree and think about it
imagine you you drive your energy and
your sustenance from inside yourself
from stores storage that you've
established so you can go outside of
your spaceship and you don't have to
breathe the air because you have some
source of air or whatever is your need
for staying alive inside you but that
only lasts a certain amount of time is
that any different from an egg laid by a
chicken egg cannot survive if yep in our
atmosphere and I and it stays in there
until all the egg resources turn into a
chicken that can that's a so an egg is
like a space suit for embryo an egg
shell right and then with me I'm with
you on it let me just give one more
10-second quick answer to this question
right an astrobiologist to once
challenged
me to tell her why a star is not alive
and if I was unable to do that which I
wasn't right then maybe all the stars
out in the universe our form of life not
DNA but just as alive as we are yeah the
stars can be produced themselves they're
born live out their lives and die and
they have a metabolism this satisfies
almost every definition of life a
biologist would hold for us all right
but do they have agency when does a stop
become alive okay next all right
Christopher got all the time for one
more go all right Christopher Johnson on
instagram asks there soon to be an
explosion of cube sets around Earth Oh
No near future shaping out with space
becoming more accessible commercially
and to the pond Oh Josh go this is not a
lightning round answer but the bottom
line is that it's very exciting to have
all these satellites out there but it's
also very dangerous both for science and
for human beings over time we have to be
very wise about how we send those things
up there it has to be very carefully
controlled otherwise we're gonna really
regret having all those things don't
even keep track of where they are you
can but again it requires a lot of
advanced planning you can't just say
have a company go send it up but
thousand satellites whoo-hoo that's
gonna cause us all problems yeah I would
say the reason why we haven't been
visited by aliens because they see all
this crap orbiting Earth I'm not coming
near that place yeah that's my sound
byte so Charles thanks for coming on it
was my pleasure Thank You Man I really
really like coming regular we got a
little the flash in there and and
spider-man always a little superhero
action when I've got to do some
slaughter that stuff it Matt always
great to have you so ways a place to be
here as well probably science thanks for
staying you just came over on a red-eye
so thanks for doing the show
thank you I'm crops up my coffee right
now the museum's finest cuffs all right
excellent I this has been star talk some
of you might have seen it most will have
listened to this episode of cosmic
queries celebrating space week I've been
your host Neil deGrasse
Theisen and we've done the show from my
office at the Hayden Planetarium
American Museum of Natural History as
always I bid you to keep looking up
[Music]